ça suffit qui veut être avec nous c'est
n'importe quoi
diémé ici les gens qui arrivent sur des
inutiles selon yann malet fou quoi là
mais qu'est ce que nous faisons
on reçoit un garçon que j'adore sylvette
comment ça va mon kiné gecko tonnes le
bandage
on est fort vador regardez regardez
c'est ça qu'on veut c'est de l'éclater
voilà c'est sur le côté
non mais sérieux c'est sur le côté c'est
françois fillon si en fait il est
devient ouf c'est bouaké man j'adorerais
fait recette
je sois non mais non mes doigts mais toi
tu as beau temps il a une belle qualité
de cheveux c'est vrai moi je fais moi je
fais ça ça ne fait pas du tout à fait
pas du tout je te lis j'essayais
d'adhara fois on aurait dit un tampon
gex était dégueulasse
du coup la vérité pour nos
téléspectateurs quand vous étiez
pompiers est ce que vous avez déjà eu
une ouverture et vous avez conclu
dites moi pas loin alors qu'on n'a pas
le droit mais bon on est aussi on n'a
pas le droit à ça va ça va c'est fini
non sans rigoler je le sais pas moi
pendant l'intervention
papandréou après comment ça s'est passé
après les numéros c'est pas parce qu'ils
sont inconscients
racontez nous un truc un peu fou si en
bas on avait eu une intervention où la
demoiselle était plutôt que charmante
way et en repartant ce n'était pas
arrivé à moi par contre alors partant
elle a demandé à mon collègue son numéro
et alors il n'y a pas de données voyons
pas les histoires pour rien d'un cador
il va pas donner ses bars et ses risques
et des défauts s'appelle justement pour
faire venir les pompiers
ouais on s'éduque sur moi j'étais en
campagne d'accord donc c'était plus
calme on a par des chats bien des
coquins moi je me suis déjà fait draguer
par un pompier alors que je venais de me
faire
non mais c'est imaginer c'est un genre
en fait c'est imagine c'est un genre de
koh lanta rentrer mais quand on est tous
ont entre mecs à la caserne il ya deux
filles avec elle en a elles sont prises
accord c'est vrai que quand on voit une
fille tu as l'impression qu'on a lâché
un peu les chiens mais mes oraux on
était sûr keen'v keen'v avec son nouvel
album chaletains banques et qu'il devait
vous avez participé à l'émission splash
le grand plongeon
vous avez appelé pour qu'elle vous a
rappelé pour le faire mais non j'avais
mais c'est pas tout à l'heure on s'est
croisés et ça fait une heure que je
cherche dans quelle émission non
meilleure ville a fire d'excusés aussi
danse avec les stars et puis c'est un
grand c'est un chanteur qui cartonne oui
ça je sais est arrivé mais je savais
qu'il y avait une émission en plus vous
l'avez vu à la piscine c'est en fait son
gré pour qu'elles ont recommencé mettais
mon slip de bain d'abord connaître tout
de suite je suis moi je sais qu'on fait
une émission ici dollars par mois mais
rappelez-vous dans la semaine vous voyez
pas que
[Musique]